let p be an odd prime number and t sub p
be the following set of two by two
matrices so it's a set of matrices where
each member we're just calling it a
where a could be made up of lowercase a
b c and a and then these could take any
values between 0 and p minus 1. and
remember p was an odd prime number and
frankly all the prime numbers greater
than 2 are odd so the number of a in tp
so the number of matrices such that a is
either symmetric or skew symmetric or
both and the determinant of a is
divisible by p is so let's just make
sure we understand what symmetric and
skew symmetric mean so let's think about
symmetric first so a matrix is symmetric
if it equals its transpose so in this
case
a matrix a b
a b c a
and that's what our the members of the
set look like this is symmetric if this
is equal to its transpose and a
transpose of a matrix you just swap the
rows in the column so this first row
here a b will become the first column a
b and the second row c a becomes the
second column c a so that's what
symmetric means
now if you just look at this that means
that a is equal to a a is equal to a
this essentially means that b will have
to be equal to c in any of these
matrices that are symmetric because that
would have to be equal to that and that
would have to be equal to that fair
enough now let's think about what skew
symmetric means
skew
skew symmetric
skew symmetric just means that a matrix
is equal to the negative of its
transpose so skew symmetric would mean
that
a
b
c
a
is equal to the negative of its
transpose this is its transpose of the
negative of its transpose
is negative a
negative c
negative b
negative a and so the two results from
this mean that a would have to be equal
to negative a a would have to be equal
to negative a which essentially means
that a has to be equal to zero
which means that a is equal to zero the
only number especially in this set where
it equals a negative of each other
that's frankly the only number where you
equal the negative of yourself is zero
so that means a equals zero it also
means that b
must be equal to negative c or that c
must be equal to negative b so it also
means that b is equal to
negative c so that's what either of
these mean
now
either of these are going to be true we
want to find the number of the number of
members of the set such that either of
these are true and the determinant of
the matrix is divisible by p and
remember the determinant let me just
write this over here as a reminder the
determinant of a matrix a is equal to
a we could write it like this a b c a
and it's just equal to a times a or a
squared minus b times c minus b times c
so in this situation over here the
symmetric matrix the determinant here
is going to be equal to a squared
a squared
minus b times c but we know that b is
equal to c because it's symmetric so
it's going to be minus we could say
minus b squared
and over here what's the determinant
going to be equal to the determinant
of a is going to be equal to a squared
we know a is zero so that's just going
to be zero minus b times c minus b times
c so minus b times c
if we substitute for c we know that c
is equal to negative b so we also know
that
we could write negative b is equal to c
so this is the same thing as negative b
times negative b which is equal to
b squared so if the matrix is symmetric
we know that its determinant is going to
be a squared minus b squared if it's
skew symmetric its matrix is go its
determinant is going to be equal to
b squared which is frankly going to be
the same thing as c squared now let's
think about how many matrices satisfy
this where this determinant is going to
be divisible by p
so this needs to be divisible by p so
first let's just factor this this is the
same thing just because it looks
tempting as a plus b
times a minus b so this is the
determinant in the symmetric case and it
needs to be divisible by p which
essentially means it needs to equal some
integer constant times
times
p and remember p was an odd prime number
and it's an odd prime number larger
larger than any of the possible a's or
b's the a's and b's can only go up to p
minus one they start at zero and they
can only go up to p minus one so this is
larger this is larger than any of these
numbers now let's think about how this
would work in order for this to be
divisible by p that means either this
the first term is divisible by p or the
second term is divisible by p let's
think about that either the first term
or the second term is divisible by p or
i guess in theory both terms divisible
by p so we could say either
either let me just write it like this so
one of those are going to be divisible
by p so let's think about how these
could be divisible by p
so the only way that this term right
over here could be divisible by p so a
minus b divisible
by
p
so let's think about that how can this
be divisible by p a and b are both less
than p
so their their their difference is only
their difference is always going to be
smaller than p their difference is by
definition going to be smaller than p so
how can it be divisible by p well the
only way it's going to be divisible by p
is if it's zero zero is the only number
smaller than p that is divisible by p so
the only way that this is going to be
divisible by p if a minus b
if a minus b is equal to zero or that's
the same thing as saying that a is equal
to b
now how many possibilities are there for
a being equal to b
well we'll just look at all the
possibilities there's there are if we
look over here there are p possibilities
right you have one two three let me
write in a darker color this is a could
be zero that's one possibility two
possibilities three possibilities and if
you were to just count all the way up it
would be p notice when i'm counting it
it's one more than the number i'm
counting so this was p possibilities and
then b has to be the same thing so
there's not much freedom in selecting a
b once you select the a so there are p
possibilities where a is equal to b p
possibilities p
possibilities
there are p possibilities of that
happening and let's just keep in mind
one of so a it might be equal to 0 which
is equal to b so this would include both
of them equaling zero both of them
equaling one both of them equaling two
all the way to both of them equaling p
minus one so there are p possibilities
of this
and let's think about how a plus b could
be divisible by kp so remember both a
and b both a and b are less than p
both a and b are less than b so just as
a thought experiment could a and b
could a and b
so a a plus b could be equal to zero
times p that is a possibility but
frankly when you think about it that
means that a would have to be equal to
negative b but both of these are
positive numbers so that's not a
possibility so actually a plus b can't
be 0 times b i said 0 times b based on
just these are both smaller numbers but
then they would have to be the negatives
of each other and both and these numbers
are not negative or well i guess let me
let me take that back this could this
would work in the situation where both a
and b are zero but we already included
that in this over here we already
included that in these p possibilities
where a and b are both equal to zero so
let's not add to that now let's think
about because this isn't a new
possibility
a plus b is equal to p
well that's completely possible and how
many situations are there where a plus b
is equal to p
so if you pick your a it completely
determines what your b is going to be
your b is going to have to be p minus a
so can a
can a be equal to zero
well no if a was zero b would have to be
p and we know that b cannot be p b can
at most be p minus one so a can be one
and then b would be p minus one a could
be two then b could be p minus two all
the way to a being p minus one and then
b would be one so there are
over here
there are two minus
let me see there are actually limit
there are p
minus one possibilities
p minus 1 possibilities and notice they
don't overlap and none of these
possibilities is either a or b equal to
0 or
is either a or b equal to each other so
they're never going to be equal to each
other because p over 2
because you don't have a situation where
a plus b is equal to p where they're the
same thing because if they were the same
thing you'd go to this one and you know
this is never going to be the case
because this is a prime number if it was
possible that b could equal a and this
equation hold you would have 2a is equal
to p a is equal to p over 2 which would
mean that p is divisible by 2 but it's
prime it can't be divisible by 2. so
these are all p minus 1 distinct
possibilities they don't overlap with
any of these a a and b are never equal
to zero and a and well frankly a never a
and b never equal each other in these
possibilities so so far just from the
symmetric case we've counted up p minus
one plus p possibilities so we've
counted up
we've counted up a total of two p
minus one possibilities i just add up
all of these possibilities now let's
think about the situation of being skew
symmetric when you're skew symmetric the
determinant of a is equal to b squared
or we can we know that and we want the
possibilities where the determinant is
divisible by p
so b squared would have to be equal to k
times
would have to be equal to k times p so
let's think about this if b times b is
divisible by
p
if b times b
is divisible
by p
divisible by p remember both of these
are smaller than p and p is prime that
means that either one of these or
essentially it means that b would have
to be divisible by p
it means that b would have to be
divisible by p
and the only way that b is going to be
divisible by p since b is smaller than p
is if b is equal to zero zero divided by
any number other than zero because when
you divide by zero it's undefined but
zero divided by the other number you
have a zero remainder so you can view it
as divisible so you could say okay
here's another possibility here but we
have to be very very very careful we
already included that possibility over
here we already included the possibility
we already included the possibility of b
b equaling zero in this combination in
this combination here where a is equal
to b is equal to zero and let me be
clear we already said over here so you
might say wait over here we're just
saying b is equal to zero we're not
saying that a and b are equal to zero
but remember in the skew symmetric case
a has to be equal to zero so in the case
where b is equal to zero you're seeing
that a and b are equal to equaling zero
but that was one of the possibilities
that we considered here so that would
work but we already counted that
possibility so there's a total of two p
minus one possibilities where
where
a is either symmetric or skew symmetric
and the determinant of a is divisible by
p so two p minus one the only answer
choice is d